do you really know what's in your
multivitamin sugars gmo synthetic
fillers artificial colorants not to
mention animal by-products like sheep's
wool
gelatin from hooves and hides all these
ingredients you might find in a
multivitamin
multivitamins are a lot of them are
scams ooh
sneaky they have like a bunch of trash
in them the whole point isn't supposed
to make you healthy
why would you put think about that how
think about how sick that is
that people have charlatans have had the
audacity
to put chemicals animal byproducts
synthetic fillers and gmos and sugar in
vitamins
ritual is the multivitamin reimagined
rituals formulated with
nutri nutrients including vitamin d3 to
help fill gaps in the diet
the refreshing taste delayed release
capsule are designed to dissolve later
in less sensitive areas of the stomach
so you can take them without
or with food with or without food which
is shocking honestly i know
ritual is made traceable you'll always
know where your nutrients come from
thanks to rituals one of a kind
visible supply chain ritual is designed
with different life stages in mind now
available for women
men and teens rituals multivitamins are
scientifically developed to help support
different
life stages because we're the things
because sometimes i'm a teen and
sometimes i'm a man
so yeah my ritual makes healthy habits
easy your multivitamins are delivered to
your door every month with free shipping
always you can start you can start
snooze or cancel your subscription at
any time and if you don't love ritual
within the first month they'll refund
you
your first order you deserve to know
what's in your multivitamin that's why
ritual is offering my listeners whitney
listeners 10 percent off during their
first three months
visit ritual.com whitney to start your
ritual today
i got i got double tested today i got a
blood test
and a mouth swab and a nose so i'm
super negative okay so everything can be
cut out everything or nothing manager
we don't even need to air this she gave
me permission to tackle her as well
love that like it's we're good
um how do you do this
so i have a podcast too and i'm like
just learning how to be the one that
asked the question so now i need to
watch you in full action
well the first thing that's gonna happen
is i'm gonna have a perfectionism spiral
and tell you cannot bang on the tape
because it's gonna make an awesome okay
so that's gonna be really hard for me i
speak with my hands a lot fuck
so you're not supposed to jingle jangle
should i take off my teeth i mean but
are you you're a music producer no you
i might turn into like a drum sound yeah
but that's
the people are driving they're on their
a jog they're at the gym
they're like doing their dishes
everything is music whitney
so you're i mean you're wearing teeth
like what should i take them off or they
to jingle jingle
okay i like the teeth what's with the
teeth okay the teeth
are i asked my fans to send me teeth
so i could wear them and i've made a
headdress and multiple pieces of jewelry
out of their teeth and i wear it when i
just like need good luck
these are your fans teeth on your back
yeah yep obsessed with you
and i thought it was just like but they
they were pulled out from dentists
uh yeah like wisdom teeth mostly i got a
couple of like
questionable teeth that had like a
little bit of remnants of what
seemed to be i didn't test it but it was
like red dried liquid
seemed like maybe pliers people were
pulling their teeth out for you
there like is a possibility that maybe
that happened
talking to you is not like pulling teeth
think
i want to bang on the table
usually pop stars might be like pulling
teeth
so these are your fans teeth yes i love
my fans i miss them
so much so i take their teeth with me so
are we friends
well
i'm gonna answer you look at this
oh my god oh my god am i getting my mind
blown
my own podcast how dare you
is this going to embarrass me no it's
literally
just what we were just opening it it's
really not that exciting it's not like
something fancy
can be cancelled
if this gets you cancelled this gets you
canceled we're all fucked
well yeah
you told me in a voice memo you said in
a voice
memo that all you want in life is a box
with a horse in it so
are we friends hey this is like
theomon's mullet
is this me yeah
is this a voodoo doll no it's just like
you wanted a horse in a box
you said that's your favorite thing in
the whole world boxing helena
i don't know your brain he just said all
i want in life is a horse in a box
so i tried to make that happen i am
you can throw it away go now i need you
to leave
i'm done with the business she needs to
come i quit charlie's hair
this where did you buy this i'm not
gonna tell you yeah i want
yeah that's why you're here i am that's
really
what you didn't say i couldn't ask that
so where did you buy this place
it's very fancy it's from target it's
from
down the street that's why i was late
how many children died how many
children's fingers were cut off
you'd be surprised there's like three
horse options at target
really i know that's probably excited
bottom line maybe
they're all hanging from the trees i'll
be cute
and so this is me yeah that's you where
did you get this that was also a target
purchase
you walked into target oh we did
together you and target must be a real
scene oh it's i had to contain myself i
love target when i go to target
i am benton or what are you texting
are we not entertaining
you're the two icon legend stars of your
childhood
am texting olivia munn about our
thanksgiving
oh oh i'm on that group chain yeah so
check me out
no sometimes i look at my phone it's
like 400 text messages
can you focus on me please yes what what
is
where is this what do you mean where is
that in your hand it's in your hand
i mean wait what about me and target
what happens oh my god
what do you guys think when he goes to
the target first of all she got lost she
gets lost immediately as soon as she
walks the door she'll call and go where
am i and i'm like what do you mean where
are you
like i'm just so overwhelmed and so
excited
dude i grew up west virginia virginia
you go to walmart and you're just like
oh tennessee i know that i i went there
after prom
so do you know that benton you went to
walmart for prime after prom
tennessee wow i stole my shoes for prom
from a kmart and i walked in and put my
dirty old shoes in the box and walked
out in these like really tacky
fake stiletto heels and those are my
prom shoes
from kmart gotta get that picture from
that i
mean and then do you know that benton
sold you makeup in nashville
okay so we've talked about this did you
what did you sell me was it the blue
lipstick everything
i used to make blue waterproof liquid
liner
for as little and you would wear it as
lipstick yeah it was basically the exact
color of your hair
yeah and when it had like glitter in it
yeah and when it went out of stock you
bought all of them
i literally called like the headquarters
and i was like i need them
all because on stage i'm a real i'm real
cool boss lady
i'm like do your thing but when you get
on stage you have to cover yourself in
glitter and put blue lipstick on
so it's like kind of my only rule so i
like
bought out the rest of the blue eyeliner
that i found like 35 of the other day
and i was like what do you do with
35 oh yeah you're over right now oh my
god i can't help it
my fucking pants i get in trouble for it
too
i have misophonia so how did
why were you getting eyeliner and
putting it on your lips um
because that eyeliner didn't move it was
like it was like waterproof sweat proof
smooth it does not move like you can
pour a beer on your
eyelid a blue lips why do you want blue
hair
i'm 38 and childless okay well i was
like
24 and clueless and i also just like
think
there's a part of me that likes to i
never wanted to be like
the pretty girl i always wanted to be
like i feel like a blue tiger
is my like spirit and so when people
like look at me and like
they're like oh like you're not cute or
you are cute and it's like no no no
i'm a blue tiger like just
leave it alone i'm a blue tiger
translate that
she's saying that she just wants to be
herself uniquely individual without all
of your labels without asking the
question
no you can totally ask that question
this is the tennessee
goddess thing no it's actually like a
very
um the feminine is dark and is actually
cool i like being cold and it's blue and
the
i just found this out i have two blue
tigers tattooed on me
and the tiger well one's underneath like
a
spandex bodysuit but
i just like i really identify as a blue
tiger
that's what i'm saying and so i think
the blue lips was also like
fuck societal beauty standards and it
was like my tiny little rebellious being
like
i'm gonna wear blue on my lips because
i'm not supposed to also to be fair
nobody was doing it when
nobody was doing it no it was like a
whole thing where it was like
i got yelled at in tennessee
it was at the green hills mall i believe
green hills mall at the mat counter at
the green hills mall
but where were you born oh i was born in
van nuys
at home that tracks and then my mom
at home birth home birth i met your mom
so i feel like
you're like a mad genius thanks
so are you okay
she doesn't know how to accept
compliments so no no we met before that
by the way
in another in another in another life
we'd have but so
but i i feel like some very like
like you know when you meet someone
you're like we're close yeah and you're
just like okay
we're all caught up yep gotcha we're
just on a different vibration yeah
and i think that's the appalachian
connection you mean like we're
hillbillies
i get canceled every time i say that
word but yes you can't say
what is this world we live in where i
cannot call myself a hillbilly i know
right
hillbilly i can't say amazing doctor
canceled new york made an amazing
documentary called hillbilly
it's on hulu it's incredible
um can i call myself white trash yes
great because you are okay
um so i like i just feel this like
i don't know i just you also were like
in my
the way that you sort of like
infiltrated my life
before i knew you maybe i just felt like
i knew you maybe this is just what
the great pop stars do is like you gave
me permission to be
authentic and so i thought i knew you
better than i did do you get that i
really love that no i don't get that's
like
what am i just a fan ew cute
well i'm here what give her a tooth
yeah give me your ginger too many prove
this to this
honest my music taste is very weird i'm
very weird with music
i am too i'm super weird i'm so
sensitive that i don't like listening
to music all the time like i i don't
either i don't listen to music all the
time
i listen to allison krauss
i love thoughts oh my god my heart
i listen to like allison krause mary
shaping carpenter like about dina carter
well that's when we really fell in love
was it strawberry wine so you and i
did carpool karaoke together
i was so bad at singing that day i was i
forgot all the words
better oh my god i knew your songs
better than you knew your songs
i record i have a playlist on
this is such a ridiculous story so
they call me about carpool karaoke and
i'm like i
never know how famous i am so i'm like
okay you're
very famous i don't know about it yes
like
i am inspired to do a podcast from you
you're like the beyonce of podcasts
benton what i'm not saying nothing about
beyonce
am i about to get stung by b no i love
beyonce beyonce is my favorite that's a
huge compliment no but i just you never
know they could be anywhere
i mean that in the highest respect of
i'm gonna get
murdered so i get a call that's like
carpool karaoke is
karaoke is happening i hate karaoke i
cannot sing
i love karaoke but for different reasons
go on i don't cause you can sing
no no no no no no no no
when i do karaoke because i can't take
myself seriously and i feel like it's
kind of
douchey to like i'm a singer i'm gonna
sing this song and look at me go
i try to make them turn my microphone
off by being so bad
and so for me karaoke is
in the same category of like idiot
shivers i try to like give people
that like really feel like when you
watch really bad stand-up
shot infertile what like like um
uh like you're like cringe
i love cringing i love cringing you're
like yes
that's like your you've got like a
manson
marilyn manson charles manson
charlie manson pipes marilyn monroe
no like i i want people to feel
comfortable like i don't want them to
feel uncomfortable
but i love cringing yes well
this is why because that's what i did
with the robot special
the can i touch it special oh my god the
robot is so awkward
like i when i brought i didn't even know
i was going to include in special
and there's a certain thing that happens
after you've performed a lot where
you're like you want to give the
audience
more you want to give them a feeling
they've never had like a new thing
you want to get some feeling they've
never had before and it's like okay i
can make you laugh i can make you clap
i can make you cry laughing now i want
to make you go
now i want to freak you the fuck yeah
yeah now i just want to give you that
adrenaline because i know it turns into
dopamine like i just want to spook you
i love spooking people like you're
scared yeah
they're gonna weird you out yes i think
going back to the blue lipstick i wanted
people to be like
huh and like not know how to feel
it is that and is it is does that come
from a place of insecurity because i
think
i'm constantly shocked by how shy you
are
yeah i am pretty sure like in personal
life i'm very shy very shy
yeah well i also take a long time here's
what i've learned i'm like a sphinx
you're like a cat you're like a like a
you're like a savannah cat like a blue
like
tiger but like there's a little bit
obviously a dissonance
of i googled you yesterday oh my god i'm
so so sorry i feel it
that's where the nervous breakdown came
from no i never have googled myself
truly i know people say oh i never
google myself
i think i googled you and said that uh
google told me that you had a tail
oh i do i did a doctor stole it
i still wear it to god he did not tell
me he was taking my tail off
and took my tail keep going nice
please it wasn't like bait
no it wasn't like saying the clickbait
please
this is a real story we should call my
mom i had a tail oh we are gonna call
we're gonna call because i did have a
tail it was very small
and it when you were born yeah and like
up until i get an
adult yeah just like a little it looked
like a mole but then i was like what is
this
and they were like well technically it's
a tail
so when i was getting a yearly
checkup how old were you like in my 20s
oh yeah this doctor stole my
motherfucking tail
and like didn't ask permission just was
like zapped it right off
and i was like let me put it in like a
case or something
let me put it on a necklace now you're
just bragging about having health care
no i just i miss my tail
so you were born with the tail just like
a not like it's not like a dinosaur tail
i was born with an extra bone in my foot
really my right foot
left foot wait left foot is feminine
and that is also associated with
nighttime and darkness
i'm learning all of this from who from
the internet
from the comments no it's a long story
but yes
but it what maybe you need an extra toe
on that foot because you had a lot of
feminist shit plow through
um uh i remember when the carpool
karaoke thing came in it was like
did i make this up they were like kesha
wants to do this with you
oh i requested strawberry wine by dina
carter
and me yeah and then but i had no idea
that you were
i can't say hillbilly
you can no you can here you can okay in
my office
may i permission
are we all good do you identify as a
hillbilly
i hope so well that's between you and
yourself
okay so well
it's like the word redneck you know the
word redneck growing up like i always
thought that was um like i i guess i
just made this up or
that it was about i thought it was a tan
tan on your neck no
it actually is about um the battle of
blair mountain
it was uh uh the second largest labor
uprising in history was in west virginia
and they wore red bandanas and they
called them rednecks so randoms are
actually
heroes which is the sequel to escape
from which mountain oh
my god i had no idea so what's the like
is it etymology of hillbilly we've
recorded a podcast and never got to air
it
um about this exact thing remember we
went to west virginia
yes i do remember you went to west
virginia
but let me ask you like how
do you have siblings i have two brothers
one older one younger
okay oh yeah they're your editor yes
where are they
one is living literally next door
i mean kind of but i'm the only girl
okay so
i'm the favorite what is it about you
tennessee people
but what is it it's a very vague
question yeah i don't know
like i should be insulted or flattered
it's your witches
oh my god absolutely but you're
definitely a witch as well
so clearly so i don't know i don't know
if it's just
like maybe it's in the water i don't
know i think
honestly i grew up chasing fireflies and
like
running through the hills barefoot and
there was that connection to nature
from the beginning which i know you have
too it's just like you love animals
i think that's another thing we like
bonded on yeah that's right
and i think the more connected i am to
nature the more i feel like a witch
[Music]
and sparkles so but then how do you
how do you with this vibe
how do you go into a business meeting
with a bunch of
guys in suits that are like do what i
mean
yeah well if you were a bunch of guys in
business suits
i would wear some like don't fuck with
me shoes
so like how how do you this is a weird
question
okay we can cut it and go like
when i see you when we're not rolling
we've hung out when
cameras aren't happening and you're
kesha
like the person who i'm saying yeah like
this is who you are
i'm saying like i have this idea in my
head that pop stars are like
i'm a pop star today and they put on
their wig and their necklaces and their
things and they're glitter and they're
like i'm a pop star you know what i mean
it's like
that's just who you'd be even if you
weren't famous yeah i
definitely think like 10 years of like
performing on a stage has
influenced my lifestyle like i probably
wouldn't have
human teeth on a necklace like things
like that might be different yeah but
i have always been if you weren't famous
that's a crime
but it was all just i just i just
suggested
if anybody had any teeth i know but is
this legal
that's a really good question i mean
it's i didn't
no one was harmed if you go by me to the
doctor
you can't keep your organs um my mom
when she had me at home i think it all
started with my mom
my mom's like the queen witch like she
is like narnia it's your mother
it's always your mother she had me at
home and then
went to the hospital they took her like
placenta came out
sorry crack your beer girl sorry it's
not
do it so my mom goes to hospital
placenta won't come out whatever so she
like left me at home with her friend
a couple friends i'm just like hanging
out newborn baby
and finally her placenta falls out
and the lady's like okay you can go now
and she's like no give me my placenta
and so she negotiated for her placenta
to be
shoved in a garbage bag underneath the
dumpster outside so
then at the age of 24 and i was gonna
wear it today but i couldn't find it
she ground it up in the blender and put
it in a necklace that i like to wear
so the moral is if you're just annoying
enough
you can get your organs that's true my
dad kept his hip bone from his hips
see there you go and i just went on a
date with a doctor and he let me draw
blood out of my body
to put into vinyl records wait wait wait
wait wait
wait wait you went on a date with a
doctor
well yeah he was cute but i was like
also
i need to imagine being a doctor being
like i'm just gonna where did he take
it well would you a dentist could that
would be helpful no this is like a
separate
um project is he available where is he
now
he was a cute doctor i was like i am
single i would date you you are a doctor
you are nice yeah i i think having
that's a good call
and he's a like ear nose throat that'd
be so helpful in my line of shit
[Laughter]
checks a box and we were just like chat
and flirt and i was like okay listen so
i did a song with the flaming lips and
when coin was like can you get a vial of
your blood because we're gonna put it in
the vinyl like in the inside
so when you spin the record like your
blood's gonna be swirling around
and i was like that sounds awesome so
then i went to the doctor and he's like
well you need the blood in your body
it's not just a little bit just a little
bit so i went and i was just like
chatting with him being like so
can we do this and he was like well it's
not technically legal
and then we just chatted some more and
then
it became legal
in like 10 minutes
i don't remember the point it's so
odd like you're like you're just so
what i'm so curious what word's gonna
come next
why i'm just like you're so and i'm like
random
it's so random no i'm just excited no
i'm just like
i'm obsessed with you because like i
really i'm so scared of pop stars
like are you scared of me no yeah of
course why
i'm the gentlest i'm like a baby
whale no it was just hard
i can't you love a baby well i love the
baby whales too but i just um
uh i'm just like fascinated by
this like how you've managed to stay
kesha
do you know what i mean like have you
broken or have you broken open have you
broke
you know i think you know i just put
this in a song the other day
can i get a no it's already been written
[Laughter]
no for real like that's where i get song
inspiration is like you say some
crazy ass thing and i'll just be like
i'm already all right you theme song
how do you do that you already have you
already have a theme song you already
have a things like yeah yeah
well do we have one we got a jingle but
you do and it's catchy okay
you don't need to jingle uh i forget the
point oh
song lyric that i wrote it's like i
thought that i was broken
but i was only broken open yes yes so i
feel like
as cheesy and like go fuck yourself
as it is it's like the hard things in
life that are just like the most
miserable parts of your life i sometimes
look back on and i'm like
well i would not be like i would not
know how to do so many things
i wouldn't be as tough i wouldn't be as
vulnerable i wouldn't be as open
i wouldn't be as adventurous and i
wouldn't have met people like you
like it's just like yeah life takes you
on a journey and you have to like either
get into it or you can be scared of
everything your whole life
yeah and it's just like and you have to
have contrast and this is why i love
comedy and this is why
um i think i do it and why maybe
podcasting
is works on some level is like every
time something bad happens to me it's i
just i'm like
oh i can alchemize this i'm gonna use
i'm gonna utilize it into making someone
cringe
in that feeling that you like so much i
like making people cringe i
love making people dance myself well
yeah i mean there is an element to that
if you can take something that like
truly
sucks like let's just say in general a
breakup it sucks it breaks your heart
you want to die
but if i can take that and then write
like a cunty fuck you song about it that
makes people giggle
then i'm like oh i just took the thing
and made it into a thing that
people are laughing about and it's happy
you said dancing with tears in my eyes
oh my god deep cut oh bouncy because
the deepest stuff oh my god stephen i
gave stephen
sorry we just have to like side note on
this for a second okay stephen
i gave stephen the steven i wrote a song
on when i was 16 called steven still
friends with the guy
gave him a tattoo of my name about right
before like
covet happened wow so i feel like i won
i mean by the way here's my thing you're
always
i i think we're in a time where the good
is
always going to win i don't know about
it always but maybe eventually
eventually it's like eventually
like star wars it's like but i think if
you forgive you win
as soon as oh my god this song lyric i
just told you is in this song called
i forgive you you plagiarized me no i
wrote that
song
um and then okay so i just want to go
back to this because i like to get
really
everyone knows this about me i like to
get super granular we were doing carpool
karaoke together and it was
it was a weird pairing yeah why me
uh because you're funny you picked me
well you were on a list
or was i lied you were on a list did you
walk honestly i swear to god i don't
even remember anyone
because i only saw you i don't believe
you
i swear to you i don't remember who else
was on the list but i was like hands
down her she's a robot
she's a robot i want the robot version
right and i was like i have so many
roboty
questions and like i just want to know
how you feel about robots because i
talked to this guy yesterday who thinks
i know i saw that
well like we have to talk about that
okay um
who thinks like humans are being cloned
secretly and that we soon will all be
clones and then be taken to
a different planet fine sure if someone
has the time go for it knock yourself
out and then
sammy hagar was like yes and then robots
are doing
great things too and robots are aliens
and i'm like i don't even know but i
want to know like why
i love your brain because you're like
i'm gonna go there
this is you have comedian brain like me
there's some musicians and comedians
that are concentric
that are just like i'm gonna go to the
wildest place
like i said where else are you gonna go
what what am i going to stay over there
that's already been
traversed why not go into the wilderness
yes you go to the fucking wilderness and
like
your songs are funny thank you
isn't it lost
like your songs are funny thank you you
know to me like
brushing my teeth with jack daniels like
you're just like what like it's like
funny and like really um
uh makes you like interact with the
person you're singing it with
love that i love the thought of you guys
singing that hysterically at each other
i don't know why in my brain that
happens you want to compete with who
knows the words the most like it's like
it can be
louder yeah like your music or the lyric
like makes
people feel more confident than they
actually are
that's great because that's what i
always kind of else has done that
this is done who else does that i was
going to say a chair woman you make me
feel like a natural woman maybe
chair makes me feel confident cher makes
me feel confident
um beyonce makes me feel very confident
my walkout song for
a good two years was woman my songwoman
yeah
i loved them no i just want to make
people feel confident because
we all are insecure including the person
writing it but
for when i need to pick me up i'll
listen to beyonce or i'll listen to
dolly parton or i'll listen to lizzo and
i'll just be like
bitch pick yourself up you're the shit
yes don't let this shit get you down go
do your business you have a
motherfucking business woman
like don't let this petty shit get in
your way get up
smile bitch let's go and i kind of just
need to like kick my ass into shape when
i'm being like super
emotional which i am very emotional
don't let the bastards get you down oh
my god that's my favorite song i ever
wrote
i love having a super fan here
and a dog a super fan and a dog
it's so i cuz i remember like
i remember it's just so weird when you
like know someone and then you meet
someone and and they're in
congress like you're okay i've had a lot
of times where i'm
oh what i'm so
i'm just i can't i'm gonna eat you alive
what is up with when uh
i was so i'm such a perfectionist i
wanted so badly to not embarrass myself
on our carpool karaoke
that i memorized your song uh
and i love how religious your music is
because i grew up in the south and there
was so much religion i mean you guys can
relate
right there's just like religion that
was where i had my first
uh kiss was at outside of a super church
and i would go
so hot so hot
let me tell you um and it's like where
everybody went after school
and so i i really think spirituality
i've always been drawn to and i'm
obsessed with it i think it's like a
really beautiful thing
but religion always fascinated the hell
out of me because i'm like but wait
why are you killing them yeah like
i don't but aren't we kind of all isn't
it personal mm-hmm
like i don't crazy
just like things like that so and like i
have
things that i like to do that are like
drink my pee
that's not un holy exactly
hallelujah i'm still here still bringing
it to you exactly
oh my god your commentary where do you
have to go because cancel
like buddha i mean you really are a joke
writer
good girls know how to get hard too yeah
like i i i have to be honest like
when i was doing the um
carpool karaoke with you i had to read
that because i ca like hearing it like
you talk
you sing so fast sometimes so i had to
like
read through and i was like this is like
genius joke writing this is like roast
joke
level writing thanks well i think you
um become clever funny well we're okay
were you cool in high school
you were no no no okay
it's hard to say it's okay if you were
defining i might judge you
i was in the first part of high school i
was really tall
really young and my sister had doc
martens and i wore them
and for like and she was cool so i had
like a little bit of like ancillary
very rare you know like but then when i
moved to virginia
i was i i had literally
green hair at the time shaved in the
back nose ring
which was cool in dc and then i went to
virginia and it was
not cool it was all about preppy yes and
so i was
not cool in virginia in sports sports
football cheerleading
gap so i then i was not cool in virginia
but i
was cool in dc so it's like i i don't
know and then i
by the time i was in high school i was
like had such a bad eating disorder that
i didn't talk to anybody
so i didn't have friends oh fair i sat
in my car
benton what do i always say on this
podcast about the sponsors
they didn't stop hitting the tape oh
about the sponsors mm-hmm um what did i
say about the sponsors you always say
that
you're authentic and real and that you
love them
and that i actually use the products
that we yeah you do say that
so what's going on here now
with this something inappropriate what's
that those are your me undies
i'm wearing fully wearing my undies i'm
also wearing them
i'd like to see them no i truly am so
obsessed with this underwear
i don't even need to read the copy
listen the christmas ones are out though
oh sh why don't i have them yet the
christmas me undies are out
these are the most comfortable underwear
no
no um swampiness they don't cling to you
no wedgies
yeah no wedgies no chafing none they are
the most comfortable ever for my life
it's like a you're spooning with a guy
that's bad for you
you know he's bad for you and you're
like smelling his pheromones and you're
like i know this isn't going to end well
but like it feels so
good it's like that kind of or something
better
i'm saying it's like that like
post-coital
cuddle but not only are the best
underwear they also start crying they
have like the best socks
the socks are amazing the t-shirts the
lounge pants i mean everything is made
out of that material that's
what magic material it's not like velvet
it's like a no it's like
t-shirt it's like a vintage cheese it's
like the perfect vintage t-shirt like
it's soft
but like it's not super thin i like walk
around
like i like get excited to like put on
my meandies and like walk around naked
i'm the only other i have the only
underwear that i own at this point
you've never been looked at me more
seriously than you because i'm rich very
serious it's
it's years of collecting they deliver
them to your door there's a subscription
you can also gift it to people this year
on around the holidays
it's a great it's it is a great gift
it's a great gift for
to give your sister your mom your
grandma your aunt it's a good girl to
girl gift
it's a great gift for guys because have
you seen their underwear
um not in a while and i'm that hurt my
feelings
listen i i have so many means at this
point because they deliver them to your
door every month but i can just what
me on these oh then they deliver them to
your door every month like like the
subscription that i could technically
just wear a pair each day and throw them
away it is like
well don't do that you don't do it but i
could slice full but it's um
it's like christmas i love getting just
like a pear and then it's like
the llamas i got one with llamas on it
yes it is super great and
you can get your 50 percent off your
first order and free shipping go to me
undies dot com slash whitney that's
mandy's dot com slash whitney
for the very best underwear they're so
just don't
don't play yourself just like it's
i'm wearing them i mean highly
recommended
keep going manscaped this is our
manscape
listen the lawnmower 3.0 electric
trimmer it's
this this ad says this is the greatest
ball hair trimmer on the planet
according to rogan
it also says it's not in your ad it also
says it's not recording are we recording
but the little timer's not on they my
producers time me now
on my ads because i ramble so much i
like that we have to read rogan's
recommendation on your podcast that's
funny
i mean rogan honestly rogan does not
bullshit so i agree with them
they're just like she doesn't have balls
so we need to throw this in i've seen
more balls than rogan has i'll tell you
that right now but had you trimmed them
i've never trimmed the ball because you
didn't have the llama or 3.0
or do i that is the weed whacker that's
the nose and ear hair trimmer
which i'm obsessed with me too i love
mine oh my god i love the little
clicking that you feel when it's
trimming a hair
the clicking and the trimming like the
trick like the cutting yeah like you
feel it
it's just like oh god it's just like
i'm into it i mean that's great that's
literally how you i mean nose hair
let me tell you especially if you're a
guy with a beard your nose hairs if
you're not careful
you'll look up one day and they'll be
growing into your beard hair and you
won't even tell the difference
sick yeah that's what happens look right
here
79 of their partner's pulled admitted
they have long nose hairs
and here's the thing you don't know you
have nose hairs
but everyone else does it's like having
food in your teeth like
we see like you can't see in your nose
you gotta get on you have it you have
this problem
yeah you can look in your nose that is
an option such a bummer it's like
you know when people have um that white
stuff in the corner of their mouths when
they're talking
yeah and you're like it's yes i do but
they're dead skin and spit
but they don't know it and you're like
do i tell them do i not how do you not
know that is what i want to know
a lot of people don't disgusting well
you know your balls are hairy people
don't know that they have
first of all hairy nose hairs coming out
or ear hairs or ear hairs who's going to
tell you
you should be self-aware that's
self-awareness i know but like you have
to have a girlfriend that's going to be
like
hey okay well at least well you know if
your balls are hurting so you can at
least get that one
on your own pull your balls together
pull them together
enough is enough with the ball like
there's no more excuses
with the the the razor burn balls
and the is it razor burn is it herpes
now i have to like ask a bunch of
questions just like manscaped has like
taken all the anxiety
out of handling yes you can trim
safely trim your body hair not shave it
off like a
baby seal the guy that i uh i'm sleeping
with
stole it yeah that's i mean i travel
with that thing
i was like did you take the cuticle
trimmer the manscaped box it's like all
nail care yeah if someone steals from
you red flag
he was like yeah i did i was like well i
need that back because i have to read an
ad and i want to show it he's like also
you're a thief so there's that bring
that back and then never return you
thief don't be a thief buy your own
manscape you can get 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
whitney that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
whitney
your balls will thank you
i was in the marching band so it was
like my fault marching band
why do you say it like a ghost but that
said
[Music]
i mean marching band like that's such a
like it's a sad
scene fun sounds fun
it's one of those things that sounds fun
and then when you do it you're like this
is
your mom make you do it or did you do oh
no i fully like wanted
to do it and what did you listen to
growing up because your mom
wrote songs um music wise yeah like
uh i would just steal my brother's cd so
one of my
i think like most memorable was leanne
rhymes
the song blue and i was like that's when
i was like i want to learn how to yodel
so if there's like little moments in the
pop music where i yodel that's what
that's from
the female brain like it was such a
weird
like i i can't believe i did that like
it's so funny to look back on that i
basically just
my whole i'm obsessed with
feminine qualities like being
pathologized
as negative when they're super powers
they are super powers and when you're in
touch with them it's like
something you can't explain to someone
who's not in touch with them and men
being scared of having them because
they're feminine
but to be more powerful just take them
use them it's like
i was told growing up you're sensitive
relax
calm down oh yeah and then boyfriends go
you're psycho you're crazy you're crazy
you're crazy you're crazy
and i also doubted my reality a lot as a
child
because you have to when you're a kid
when you're in a dysfunctional situation
you can't your psyche can't handle
your parent being the problem so you
have to make yourself you have to go
well i must be crazy so
i just was in this like i must be crazy
cycle and
i read this book the female brain and
i read about neurochemicals and i was
just like
okay so i need to read this because i
just found this out as i was driving to
your house
so like draw yourself by the way i
can i can drive grounded
i'm a very bad driver i did not offer
you a car by the way
um what was my point oh i was okay
i don't google people that i'm like
friends with yeah going back to your
initials i know
we became friends with like not knowing
each other's jobs yeah
and which i love fans of each other well
we're just like
people yeah and i love when i meet
someone who's a person that i'm like i
like that person let's be
friends just happen to be famous you're
famous cool part of that to me is like a
little bit refreshing like do you ever
get on an
airplane and there's just like someone
who has no idea who you are and you're
like next sitting next to them
nice it's so nice it's like lovely to
just shoot the shit about the weather
yes yes so that's like i've taken this
approach
i don't know if it's a i don't know if
it's smart i'm not saying it's a good
thing to do but i just don't google
people that i meet and i like them
because i'm just like i'm just gonna
like you and like i'm gonna judge you on
how you
behave and the things you say and how
you act
no it's very old school but
so when i was driving over here i like
was listening to your podcast
it's a little creepy but um and then you
started talking about the female brain
or
is that what's called female brain yeah
and i was just like i
you must know so much more about the
female brain than i do
i'm obsessed with neurology because i
think
i think like we have been
gaslit and like sort of yelled at
and pathologized men and women um
without any real understanding of
neurochemicals cortisol adrenaline
epinephrine and hormones too hormones
like yeah it's just sort of like
you know i think that we're sort of
these like puppets
of our neurochemicals and it's just like
our education system is just so
backwards in terms of the way that they
um
have framed women are crazy
men are strong and it's just like they
put us in these boxes like
emotional and rational yeah emotional is
is a negative term like isn't that wild
that's a pejorative term
and like the empathy that you feel the
the feeling of wanting to stop and help
an animal which i know you know that
feeling like
that's an emotional reaction and that's
crazy crazy
crazy so the word i i have like a ban on
crazy and sorry i'm working on sorry i
still over apologize
like because if i ever my worst
nightmare in the entire world like
the feeling i hate most i'm trying to
reconcile is when i hurt someone's
feelings and had
zero intentions of doing so do you think
you can hurt someone's feelings
yes like francis was talking about how
she wore a wedge heel
that's my manager the other day and
beyonce who i'm obsessed with
obviously i've mentioned her like eight
times today but
it was like i like your wedge and i
remember
specifically a stylist like 12 years ago
being like
wedges are not okay and i was like
beyonce liked a wedge
and i've been thinking about that being
like did i hurt her feelings about her
wedge sandal
for it's been like a week now did i hurt
your feelings
okay but that's why you're you that's
why you're
an amazing writer because you're
emotional you have to be a sensitive
hyper-sensitive beast but don't you
think also to be a comedian you have to
be hyper-sensitive and you have to
figure out a way to take things that are
seemingly can be like tragic or very
very serious and you have to present it
in a way that makes people laugh but
also think
maybe not also think but just at least
laugh yes yes yes
you i think you make people think and
laugh but like some
comedians just make people laugh about
it like something
that's like they've gone through so
they've turned into a joke
do pop stars get along i
think so i've like had a really great
experience like
i invited you over and you came over and
natasha bettingfield was at my house
and then i saw you guys and i went shit
like i was worried and i was like oh am
i sexist
no there is no weirdness i assumed you
guys were competitive
not at all like zero percent
no i think you probably because you
don't know people's history with other
people and it's like
in this business it's like a grown-up
edition of
high school where it's like musicians
can like each other
i do like i'm in this boat where i have
music i like
well when i am in the mood to listen
music i gotta be honest i'm like you
were i have to be doing one thing at a
time
okay i have a question for you sorry
this is your interview but i do have a
question for you podcast
no but i actually like a i admire so
much
how amazing your podcast is and i like
i'm so excited to be your friend and
secretly like learn
kind of how you do it because you're
just so charismatic without having to
like even see the visual
it's just lovely to listen to your
beautiful voice and
and what fran drescher i thought you
said very judgey and i was like yes i'm
judging you in a really nice way
benton would quote one of your lyrics oh
i miss out
um what was the point but that's the
point i ramble
how do you keep from rambling that's
what a podcast is you just ramble on
yeah you just ramble on
well i've totally forgot the point the
point is basically like
i'm obsessed with
how you have navigated this business
and stayed
authentic my mother
okay i would say like she's like the
number one person to be like
you're being so crazy and so
extra they want you to be crazy oh i
think there's like an element that's
expected of crazy but there's always
like
could you just wear jeans in a white
t-shirt what would happen i think i
would explode
why are people so mean to lana del rey
that i don't i've actually never met her
i have no i yeah it's weird because like
last night i was texting taylor swift
and like but lana del rey have never met
that's so interesting it's so weird
it's just the weirdest i don't know
i don't know why people are mean to her
assume all famous people know each other
well i mean i think the whole world does
because like i assume that you would
know like any comedian that i've ever
mentioned but you this person you have
never met
well lana del rey is one but um
let me think about this um i've never
met
who's someone is it like someone you
would like to meet
trying to think i don't want to meet a
famous person like i i
do you don't have people that you're
like i would geek out what's the point
of me piss my pants
well what's the point what's the point
of having a podcast with two famous
people talking at each other
because there's something interesting
about it because you get a free horse
that's why
i'm just like i don't
i got star struck i get star struck by
like
people that i've like loved for a long
time
and that i've like carried their ideas
like philosophers
yeah yeah like john bojar and his dad um
robert greene we had him on the podcast
i had a full meltdown um it's weird like
what makes you nervous
um i think yeah lots of things make me
nervous um i think
like who if they walked in this room
right now are you like a person if
someone walked in right now
who's the person who you go oh my god i
need to put on lip gloss
okay wait let's frazzle you like make me
act like
i can't well it's not dolly because
you've met dolly i've met
i've i like met dolly when i was 12
years old but we recorded the song
together that was my mom wrote
separately do you have tattoos you know
i don't i don't know those we're not
allowed to say we're not allowed to know
she wears long sleeves i think she
actually recently
said something about i don't know if
she's good it's her
everybody i feel like in entertainment
you have like a little bit of a cape you
put on right
like a superhero okay so
i think that like is part of her like
separation of
her and then like who she gives away and
who she keeps for herself
who would walk in the room that would
make me like shit my pants mm-hmm
but i have met her before and i
well two people i with the first time i
met iggy pop i started like
doing the like crying like panic crying
and then beyonce
yeah beyonce like she complimented my
grammy performance and like i couldn't
even
like kept talking over her even though
she's giving me a compliment
and then jay-z was like oh it's good to
see you and i was like
yeah and like i totally didn't mean to
but i think i was like
rude to him because i was so caught in
her like energetic
light stratospheric pull
she's like saturn and and is some of her
allure i don't there's no word
um have to do with how absent she is
when she's absent
like she doesn't do captions on her
instagram
picture surprise she goes away
she just did a workout like video that i
saw this morning that made me like
so excited but she like you never know
when you're going to hear from her yes
and i think there is there's a
peek-a-boo psychologically
speaking i think talking about like the
human brain
there's always an element in any
relationship whether it's sexual or
just friendship non-sexual anything
there's always a pull and a push a chase
and a chaser and like it can go back and
forth and that's healthy and it's just
natural yeah
and i think that by being absent when
she wants to be absent and dipping in
and just like
smashing it every time like are there
teams of people in the pop star world
that go
you got to go away for a while well
usually they're like no
you gotta expose no they're like you
gotta you gotta get on every billboard
in the world for the next
all the years of your life till you die
and i'm kind of the one that's like
nobody
needs that much like countries like it's
like like
what do you mean what's up with country
it's to deal with countries
what does that mean i'm just saying like
like i'm googling you and it's like
number one hit in australia number one
the most tick tock is the most
downloaded
song did you know this i know this
from 2010 to 2020
of any song digitally oh i didn't know
that either
i knew it like broke some record but i
forgot yeah
what it was you have a 500 million
500 mil it's like a co like a
lol number of it's like a
but like to me i just like you're like
coco i hope i'm like
coca-cola i want to be the coke of music
yeah you th like i'm i i just started
reading the
your wikipedia and it's like yeah she
has the number but then it's like brazil
the number one thing is there are there
different strategies for different
countries well yeah so you tour around
the world so you go and like
visit your fans and like
show them your love back to me like
playing a show is like
you're on stage so obviously you get
this like wonderful
sense of like damn
oh like i'm so so selfishly you're like
oh i get to like play dress up
i get to wear some crazy shit i get to
dance around everyone's going to be
excited to see my stupid face like i
went and saw
what was your first concert uh ever
ever it was my first well we're talking
high school
but you're talking like first concert as
like with tick tock was lollapalooza
in 2008 or nine
bitch not a little fair bitch
oh i wanted to go on i almost did go on
lilith's fair i love
little as a performer yeah mine was
paula abdul
straight up now tell me that tape was
stuck in my car for
two years rush rush hurry hurry
oh my god paula abdul why are we
discovered keanu reeves
let's just get serious paula i met her
yes she discovered keanu reeves
she was in the room she's obsessed with
sick video
keanu reeves he
yeah do you know him i have lots of
questions about that i don't know him
would he make you like poop who would
make you poop your pants
uh i feel like you would just be like
cool with anybody or at least pretend
like would anybody make you cry like
starcraft
you know who made me cry yeah i cried on
the view once
with whoopi but the first time i met
whoopi goldberg i cried
is that like can i get
[Music]
i'm cancelled no i canceled because it's
like which
what part made you cry i guess i wonder
these moments where like
you feel like oh i just like i made it
like yes yeah yes yes ghost
was my favorite movie i was going to say
was it ghost or was it
it was obsessed with ghost remember when
she said um
uh like patrick swayze would
like was a ghost yeah and that movie is
that movie's we need to crazy
that i think we definitely need to
re-watch that one thanksgiving screening
um and uh she was like it's gas it's
just gas she pretended she farted
i do not recall this moment in the movie
she was like
she the ghost made a noise patrick
swayze is a ghost and she's like it's
gas
it's just gas and it was so fucking
funny and
she farted on the view in real life with
you
yeah and you cried when emmy ross have
we talked about this before
we've talked about this before right
i've seen it on youtube for some reason
wait wait wait
i've talked time i talk about this a lot
okay so i think i need to see this
moment to understand why it's making you
cr
over farted on the view live on the view
and like lifted her butt cheek
and like she just in my hippocampus
there's so much i just i associate her
with so much
joy um and i went on the view and it was
at a time where i was getting publicly
very dragged
i was getting very dragged publicly um i
had like
i was like the salem witch trials of the
weak woman
you know they love to do that they love
to do it did you just fart
no
[Laughter]
i thought you weren't like being funny
and i was like damn if you can time your
farts like that
you need a whatever award a big one
i would tell you
[Music]
benton can you fart for me um
um sorry there's a really emotional
story for you
go on it's so um
anyway okay you cried i cried
because the fart made you remember how
much
you loved the joy she brought you from
the movie ghost no i was like
i was just doing so much press like i
don't think people understand like
we talked about this a little bit when
with um
when zoey is on the podcast about press
like
i think when people see what we do they
see it
they see us on the tonight show and they
see you on ellen and they see you under
that they don't see that you're like
slogging and you're going from a black
car to a car
or a card or a person and you have like
five people around you and you're like
dropping your hair extensions and you're
like
oh and you're ripping off wigs and
you're throwing the heels on
through a breakup and you're like out in
your period and you're like
sick and like i don't i haven't worked
out today like you're still
a human being with insecurities and
fears and
you know um but it's champagne problems
so
why how dare you complain about it but
it's like
and i had no idea what i was doing and i
just anybody like that's my question are
any of our brains actually
fully ready to be
under a complete microscope like i know
everyone in the world self-included
thought like fame and fortune it's so
fun it's gonna fix everything it's gonna
fix every hole in my soul
like really to me i just really wanted
to travel the world and play music and
i've always stood behind like i want to
make people dance because i know dancing
is good and i want it to be super fun i
want this underlying message of like
acceptance
like radical acceptance but like i love
punk rock and i love the stooges so like
i want to be cool and like i just had
all these things i wanted to do
and then once i got that i was like oh i
still feel
very depressed sometimes and very
unheard and very unseen and like you're
saying like
a lot of my songs were written like
wanting it to be fun and funny and much
like bands i listen to that have a sense
of humor in the lyrics but then
all of a sudden i remember specifically
because i'm from nashville
there is a article in the local
like the scene is the newspaper it's
like where you
i don't know it's like the local like
ballet times or whatever
and it was like it's like she's walking
door to door
selling heroin and butt plugs to
children and i was like
because i wrote a song about brushing my
teeth with whiskey
i'm like 22. i don't understand
why that's so evil and we're like we're
having fun
aren't we we're having fun that's your
light that's
so interesting you're like um
i'm kidding it's like it's like a
meeting apologizing for a joke
yeah because you're like whoa i think
that's why we connect so strongly it's
like
we're this is play time and you guys are
taking us seriously when you're like
taking it out like a quote
out of the wrong like out of context
applying it to something else
not listening to what i'm talking about
and like dress up
right and like we're having fun because
we're here i love this quote
from the great poet pitbull
we're in here for a long time we're here
for a good time
and like i just truly am like you know
what he's right
we should have fun while we're here why
do we like i'll dive in and get
emotional
short but like i would like to promote
people feeling really happy and good
about themselves and boogieing and like
meeting friends and like smearing
glitter on themselves and like feeling
good
benton i'm hungry well luckily for you
we have the doordash app which is also
a spoonfur a spoon sir i love doordash
can you not mispronounce
spoon sir i didn't i recreated it that's
different it's a retelling you remixed
it that's your truth
listen doordash is an iconic app it is
an iconic
legend app icon legend star doordash
someone running to my door with food
stop it
look if you're not dashing to my door on
my home page
it's festive dash into the snow you're
in a dash of the snow for me
i don't even have snow here and i'm
excited about it doordash is the app
that brings you food you're craving
right now you know what i'm always
craving food 300
000 partners in the u.s puerto rico
canada and australia
local go-to's sometimes i want chipotle
i don't want to leave my home
doordash right there best friends the
whole purpose of a burrito
is defeated by going to get the burrito
i don't want anything bad enough to
leave my house for it
i just want it in my lap just dash it
my baby burrito yeah i just want to
swaddle the burrito
like i'm just i'm fully have become
one with my couch and i need you to
bring it i'm i'm
i love doordash because it's like you
get to be marie antoinette
you get to be a queen yeah the only
thing that can make doordash
better as if it was like room server
where they came in your house with a
tray and took that lid off of it
other than that perfect perfect company
right
and fed you the grape yeah and someone
had a fan
perfect company right now our listeners
can get five dollars off their first
order
of 15 or more and zero delivery fees for
their first month when you download the
doordash app and enter code whitney
that's five dollars off your first order
and zero delivery fees for a month when
you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter code whitney
don't forget that's code whitney for
five dollars off your first order with
doordash
remember when i had to go like i never
actually did it because who has the time
i remember there were days where my
friends would be like you gotta go to
this life coach you gotta go to this
nutritionist and then this personal
trainer and then this gym and then go to
shape house
this place where you go get sauna they
sound like they suck
they sound like they either have a lot
of time a friend tells you to go to a
live coach you're my friend you help me
or have a trust fund like who has this
kind of time
get a personal trainer with what money
and time just spend all day in therapy
with my life coach like what
talking about how hard it was to drive
to therapy
what kind of grown adult needs another
grown adult to tell them what to do
wild well the woot band is just like
that
only sex thing only which case
please do tell me what exactly the boot
man is not a sex thing
but it will help you be sexier
i when i wear the whoop band not
only which is all the time because you
never take it off and it's waterproof
i know which is it and it's also just
like cute the color you got me is so
yeah you can change the band so if
you're one of those people that needs
like match your whoop to your outfit you
can
i just am like a i'm an army green not
touching it you're touching it i know i
know i'm such a like weirdo about it
because i like showing it off it makes
me it's like
it makes me like myself more because i
know i'm taking care of myself and it
makes me feel like i'm
like yes i have my shit together and
when people see me wearing mine they're
like he's trying and i like that
and you know what else because it gives
you all the statistics about like how
you slept and how good your recovery was
from your workout and your
enough it tells you all the stuff i'm so
conditioned to distrust
things on a screen in print with like
fake news fake news
it's so refreshing to be like okay i
know that's true
yeah i mean i i know for for me i'm a
very like
goal-oriented person and that gives me a
goal i have something to beat and i have
something to look at yeah
and that makes me feel like because i
feel like when i work out or anything
like that
i just feel like i'm running in place
like literally like i'm not getting
anywhere productivity and cooperation
exactly
so set a goal meet it that's gary
goldman talked about the podcast yeah
that makes me feel like
oh i did something it happened
so it provides you with a weekly and
monthly performance report that tells
you how your lifestyle decisions
impact your sleep recovery and training
my lifestyle decisions that's definitely
getting feedback on your choices
yeah i mean there's like having a the
mom you wish you had
whoop has introduced the respiratory
rate into the app which is so cool it
increases uh
any increase in your respiratory rate
could be an indication of illness before
you start feeling any other symptoms i
think that's really cool
because i when i'm sick i i'm in denial
about it but the whoop band
doesn't have a bad childhood so it's not
going to be in denial yeah it's going to
cheer you on
15 off whoop is offering 15 off right
now with the code whitney at checkout go
to woop w-h-o-o-p
dot com and intro whitney at the
checkout to save 15 percent give your
money to
rogan sleep better to me sleep better
recover faster and train smarter
optimize your performance with woop
today
what's going to happen with the pandemic
and performing
that's a wonderful question that's what
i do
that is a great question that's
something i ask my
managers all the time i think until i
personally
don't feel comfortable putting my fans
in any
condition that may or may not be 100
safe so like
i know i'm holding out until i know for
sure the conditions will be
100 safe that's just my own like
that's my own moral compass yeah so
i started a podcast to talk to my
friends about weird creepy shit and
i sing songs on there sometimes it's
just words that i turn into songs
and i'm writing music but like
i'm not going to compromise somebody
else's health for my benefit
at all even if it's a benefit for them
too it's like shows are such a freeing
place i feel like they're so special
they've been live music is such a
glorious
place to go let yourself go and like
play like you're saying
like animals play and children play but
adults
like unless you're shit-faced or
something you're not when do we play
when do we get to play
when you get to listen to pop music and
go and dance around
and not worry about who is watching
because the person on stage is acting
like a jackass
kind of giving permission for all people
to be covered in glitter and act like
jackasses
that's i think my role if you could
change something about the music
industry like what would it be
um
[Music]
well i mean like
i mean like are the are grammys real
i think that turning any art into a
competition
is bullshit and just is a system
to make people feel really bad or
inflate your ego but then like
temporarily because i know
i've never won a grammy but if i did i'd
feel so
awesome and then i'd feel so bad
because i'd be like cool because i'm
like but her
songs actually kind of may be
better also like i beat my hero
yeah like i i don't want to be my hair i
want to be friends with you yeah
it shouldn't be a competition with the
person that i like what like what
are these award shows i think when you
take competition out of things
like it really the ones that didn't get
picked in dodgeball
oh my god are you making us now fucking
like i ate lunch in the bathroom under
the blower
like i already am the loser yeah i'm the
loser all the losers
get in gowns and then it's like lose to
each other i know and then feel really
bad it's just like it's a shit show like
these award shows like it's such a rat
fuck
a rat fuck i've never heard that but
that's like exactly
you know what there's something called a
rat
king have you heard of rat king uh no
all right about the red king uh a rat
king get ready to put this
in um is when rats
run around enough they their tails get
stuck together
and then they're all in a big like wheel
of rats
do they survive this uh no they die
because they can't go anywhere they i
feel like they have to move together
oh they have to work together like our
government i'm i was thinking
sounds like the world like we gotta
figure out how to work together we're
gonna
kill ourselves but maybe it's just like
symbolic for
humanity i've been really like into the
idea of like we just need to figure out
how to have a better relationship with
the earth because it's a symbiotic
relationship we need the earth to live
upon do you want kids
i don't know not like personally today
no i don't
but like maybe do you want kids
deflect you're podcasting me good
um with the right person i it's like i
want him really really bad with the
right person and i
really don't want him with the wrong
person right well i think that if you
totally adopt you same my little
brother's adopted
and i kind of helped raise him for the
first like seven years of his life and
then he came on tour with me and
whatever we're just very close family
and we all play music together and it's
very weird
but i'm into like you're saying with the
right person and under the right
circumstances like i don't need it to be
an ego trip where i'm like i need a
little me to pass on to the world
because i feel like there's a lot of
people
but if i could but the wrong people are
procreating
all the smart geniuses are like i'm
gonna not procreate because everyone's
procreating it's like well no you're the
ones that need to do it
i think if i found that exact person
that i know that
they would be taught all these like
wonderful moral
truths at such a young age so then their
development into the truth of humanity
would be there starting at so much of a
younger age and
morals and just they don't have to learn
all these things kind of like
i just like left school at 17 and it was
like let's see what works and like
thank god you know
we did it you were just like playing
bars and shit yeah
before la la liza before how do you book
a bar gig
you go to the bar and you drink it and
then you say
like i did that oh yeah there's this
place called it used to be called space
land it's in
um echo park but i played there and then
an echo
oh oh i know it they did comedy shows
yeah so you did with
um music what i did with comedy you just
like
you show up and you i had a starters
comedy show
with natasha legero and melinda hill and
we did a comedy show in echo park
at like a fucking um coffee shop oh
tropical well yeah that's where i go to
my i don't know meeting
um but
is popping that too that is the spot um
but yeah we would like i would say can i
get a spot on your show
and get a spot on my show it's kind of
like um do you know the van hyun
the three sisters yes yes okay so i've
known them since i was 18 and that's
like
we would always play these shows where
it would be like at a
play acting place and there would be
like 10 people there
yeah i would be playing a show while
jumping on a bed that's
part of the thing it was just like it's
so funny because when we met
i was like hey you know that you're the
most tick-tocked person right and you
were like huh
what's tick-tock like you didn't know
what tic-tac was well i like i'm
not like literally living under a rock i
know it's an
app yeah where you dance
and play music and drink
cranberry juice and birds and
jump into clothes there's no way that
tick tock
didn't isn't catchy because of your song
tick tock well it's even spelled the
same way in the song
i mean the app is based on your song i
would have to
like china sorry i'm so popular
is that china weird sorry i got a new
phone yesterday
um uh do you need to take that i kind of
do
take it take a break hold on you know
this is our thing you can do you
i'm going to stretch um hayam
do you know who they are i do but like i
like i know they're songs but i'm not
cool enough
they're very cool like i know them and
you know they're cool
yes so we just used to open up for each
other
yes but like anywhere but they would
take i ham
yeah it's not ham i know it's not ham
but i'm not
cool enough to understand this i'm not
not that person
i like pink like the singer or the
colors
i like pink too i'm like a cheryl crow p
bench and i were making playlists last
night and he was just like
he was so angry i'm a nostalgia person
oh me too
same i'm like i'm do you were playing
the dixie chicks
oh yeah oh i'm a tory amos sarah
mclaughlin
oh sarah mclachlan that was the first
time i ever sang a song in front of
people as i sang
in the arms of the angel which they use
now for the fucking commercials with the
animals that are on the verge of death
and every time it comes on my whole
the whole household screams and like to
try it's now associated with dead dogs
it is in like animals in cages that have
like gooey eyes and you're like no
that's the first song i ever covered so
i had my bro this is
horrifying my brother and my mom we
played the talent show
and there was like a little bit of a
track and it got off and so in the
middle of the song i went running into
the back
of the school and just like wept because
i already was like
not cool there was a whole website
before even websites were a thing that
was dedicated
to like how not cool i was
but not being cool school well now it is
because you turn the trauma into art and
then
here we are you know what else i love
about you is like
your music isn't just about boys no
i think that's like that's another boys
are like dessert
though for real i think boys are like a
really good dessert
like if they're not necessary
not necessary but like if you wanna go
for it like
when we did two bro girls it was
the whole i got in all this
like pushback because it was like a love
story between two girls trying to start
a business
they just wanted to start a business
yeah they're in their 20s and they just
love that show
money and they just wanted to just like
hook up with guys
and everyone's like well don't they want
to get married and i was like in your
20s with what money
well and in your 20s now with what money
like to plan a wedding a wedding planner
like with what like they need to make
money first they need to establish their
identities first you know that whole
thing women
skills purpose like who are who am i me
maybe and um and and i notice in your
songs like it's not
it's about there's no it's not like he
broke my heart
i used some of those like i definitely
have like heartbreak songs because i
have like grand
loves and when i love i love like so
hard it's just like insanity yeah
and i like want literally the person to
think i'm like
stars and moons are flying out of my ass
at all
like all i'm the girl that like i
pretended to not
poop for like five years straight oh
yeah
been there are you still there have you
broken that barrier i
i believe and this is a howard stern
beth stern and howard stern thing is
this like
keep it separate just don't don't talk
about it or don't don't put
it in front of the person it's very
traditional it's very sexist
however the person i'm dating i i pee in
front of but i love your hair i want to
be a pop star so
so do you hang out with other musicians
i mean i'm not like i'm not like you
i'm not let's just like roll the decks
of like best
friends and they're all super famous
like oh my god
i don't know i don't know how that
happened like
holy shit i should hate famous people
apparently you don't you're so annoying
you know more famous people than any
famous person i've ever known but by the
way i don't i don't i have not asked for
this like i just
it's like they flock to me i don't know
what it is it's just like i don't
it's because i don't know who they are
so they like me and you're like the
mother
coven witch like come in um i don't
i'm trying to think other musicians kids
i mean that's what my mom keeps telling
me
so if you have a child or something
because then you're just busy
that's what she said she's like if
you're that busy if you have a kid then
you won't like obsess about anything i
think i'm just so obsessed with making a
family
you know i'm so i think that you like to
come you like to bring community yeah
and i think that's what singers
comedians like
you know and i just got i think
cancelled today
i was on the fox news or something again
wait again
about what because i was like saying
we should listen to people that don't
agree with us oh i absolutely
think that you need to listen listening
is a very important tool that i'm trying
to develop in myself
and that i don't think all republicans
are racist and i don't think all the
people that voted for trump are racist
and so now i'm right like it's just like
we're in this
like really black and white moment you
know everyone's in so much pain right
now
that they need walls and they need like
you're dumb you're stupid you're fuck
you know it's like
um we're all in fight or flight mode
it's really weird just saying that i
just
wrote a song called the gray oh you're
plagiarizing me
i know i wrote this before we had this
conversation
she's heard this song i will see you in
cool she has heard the song
it's about what's your writing process
um
you're obviously manically prolific
that's not a word and i didn't even i
slurred when i said it
but it makes it even better um
i think and watch and observe
and feel and write it out you're alone
uh oh i work with people all the time
but like when
i was writing this one it was i have a
very sh i'm very visual so i would see
like i love
color obviously you've seen my makeup
and my face and
me um but i just saw
like everything in the world right now
feels very black and white and like
if you're not one thing then you must be
the other thing and i
was just thinking about like even when
benton was here and he was quoting
raising hell
i think i've always kind of wondered
well couldn't you be a good person
that's
like every choice you've ever made isn't
the best choice in the world but like
you're learning and that's what life is
like if you're born a buddha where do
you have to go from there yeah yeah yeah
you learn from these experiences it's
like you
i have to make mistakes for you to like
me but you don't want me to make any
mistakes
yeah and you're going to hold the
mistakes against me even if
i can then use that as opportunity for
me to grow and be a better person
and stand for more and do more with my
voice and
that's the whole like canceling thing
i'm just kind of like
i yeah where everyone's i think it's
just terror management i think we're all
just like
peak terror well i think people are
we're all stuck inside
we're all missing all the things we used
to do we're missing life where i'm
missing
my fans i'm missing tour i'm sure you're
missing connection
connection because i figured it is
really really dangerous
oh it's like my least favorite thing in
the world i've never
ever been by myself for more than like
i would say the time it would take to
sleep
let's say tonight you're at home you're
sick in bed and you're going to watch a
movie what's the movie
it would be a nicholas cage movie or
wayne's world
if i'm like trying to be happy like i
need okay so i think
also there is beauty in quote-unquote
mindless entertainment because i feel
like
chaos and also just things that are kind
of like very
not high brow art okay it's not it's not
like the
it's not the deepest shit you've ever
seen in the world
because sometimes i'm so in my feelings
all the time and writing about it and
trying to formulate it into a song and
trying to articulate things just so
and then making sure the music feel
makes you feel the way that the words
are saying and like
that's my job so then when i come home
at night
i want to watch the bachelorette and i
want to know yes who taysha
is going to go on a one-on-one with yeah
that's what i want to know and so i want
to make music
that people like the underlying message
is good but like they can also just like
dance to it be my
fuck out yes check out check out because
checking out is healthy don't make me
work
yeah like do you always have to be
talking about how
some of my songs are super heady and
then some are just like
silly goose about talking about how i
want to grow potatoes
yeah so i like doing both
and i can why do you need me to be one
thing
well i'm just gonna do all why can't i
and can't i be more than two
like god forbid couldn't i be just like
a little bit of everything yeah
no that you're crazy yep i'm crazy i'm
so emotional
i'm you're unhinged you're not allowed
to grow you're not allowed to thrive
you're not like no
you can't have a mistake you can't be
human yeah don't be sloppy
oh my god oh she might be on drugs
can you believe whenever i'm happy or
look if i'm happy i'm on drugs
and if i look pretty i've had plastic
surgery oh my god
my mom i was talking to her on the phone
she was like are you on something and i
was like i'm having a good day
that's what happened to benton last
night benton was being so funny last
night and i was like what are you
did you take one of those weed
blueberries he was like i don't have to
brush him today it's my day off the
depression i was like oh
how much time do we have same i was like
i didn't know that like let me know
it's just like humans can't handle
change oh it's i think change is the
most terrifying thing so
on my podcast i'm kind of exploring like
all things creepy which is really a
segue into
really at the end of the day i think
we're all battling
legacy the fact that we have a finite
amount of time here what happens
afterwards
and the fact that we don't know drives
is fucking insane insane
insane and we need to constantly
distract ourselves yes distraction
distraction so distract in my way of
distraction
is by focusing on what i can do while
i'm here and how i can make sure my
legacy is good and how i can if i do
take any steps it's in the right
direction at the beginning it wasn't at
the beginning it was like
i want to make as many people shake
their ass as humanly possible
which was not a negative thing because i
think dancing's
very healthy but like i've just gotten
more and more into
the intention being just like making
sure the intention is really there and
then on top of it do whatever the fuck
you want
have you ever done i did i did me
madonna it was very brief
it was very nice it was like she wasn't
that day but she was like it was an
awards show
she was like i mean maybe it was just
like her aura but she was like
quite the presence to be reckoned with
you know what i mean but she just
came in uh she's like a full team but
she came up and i think it was like me
and miley cyrus were about to go
do our own things and so we just like
popped in and took a picture and then
she like
it was like it was like a ghost it's
like
is there anything like you think should
be more famous
um like that deserves to be more famous
like i'm curious if the internet is
making people that deserve to be famous
famous like because you think about that
that's a good question that's a really
good question
i'm the best you're the best you are the
best one i have to think about let me
let me ask you in my business the
field i'm in a lot of people that
deserve to be famous aren't famous
because they don't play the game
right it's changing now um and they
don't
like do the deal and they don't like
flirt with the right people and they
don't go to the right part or you don't
wear the right thing
or the right publicist and they don't
like play the game
and they don't go to the right brunchens
and luncheons and bullshit
so there's a lot of like rigmarole that
you have to do so i'm just curious if
like in music
you know if there are people that
well here's a slight problem that i have
i
tend to like be more obsessive with like
i'm more nostalgic with music like you
are
so the music i listen to tends to be
like it's almost like a comfort
so it'll be something that was
successful
in like the late 90s like late 90s
country music is my
soul yeah yeah it's my heart and soul
and um
tusk fleetwood mac and iggy pop in the
stooges
but like all these people are famous but
i think the stooges and iggy pop like he
never
he like invented punk rock and
i feel like i don't know maybe he's got
his due but in my mind
like he should be up there in my mind
he's up there with like mick jacker
and
i don't like the beatles oh shit and
she's from shh
oh my god i just like
you don't like them at all though i
don't i was just having this argument
i mean it's like they're fine i just
don't i don't think that is it an over
saturation
it just feels like a little much so you
hate the beatles i don't hate the
beatles
you hate i don't hate the beatles i just
i'm like i feel like we're kind of all
pretending like
they're a little better than they are
but like okay maybe it was a
i'm gonna revisit i'm gonna revisit this
to be there
i thoroughly enjoy the white album
like so much especially i'm into it
but it's like a little like not a very
snappy kind of record that one but
and like i really enjoy the simplicity
of the pop songs like
i want to hold your hand it's so sweet
like
these men growing grown men singing i
find that to be really
charming and then just hold my hand
what's the big deal what's the problem
they're being so consensual i think
they're sweet
okay i just i like the beat i was having
this argument in my household
with my boyfriend yesterday because he
was like stones or beetles and i was
like why do we have to play this game
stones are beatles okay i don't i'm not
knowledgeable enough
you don't know this game no one's ever
asked you stones or beetles i'm sure you
like stones
no one would want to do that with me
because you would just be like neither
who
i hate about your head against the wall
because i want you to say what is it
i'm not a really i don't have a i have
like a very arcane music
knowledge okay who's your favorite band
inside of me that's what
i'm not a band but go on you know that i
did a
because i had to listen to your song so
many times to memorize it for carpool
karaoke that when i did a
partnership with spotify they were like
we need to see your most played songs i
think
it was all of my all kesha and they
showed it to me and i
had to do an ad saying you didn't add my
song of the year
thank you for that yeah you're welcome
worst for most like it was
so weird um and i had to be like
um uh my fa i'm like uh
my favorite band that's an impossible
like i mean like one of your i love the
lone bellow
[Laughter]
did i stump you wait is it an opera
singer i know more about music than you
the lone bellow the lone bellow
the xx i know the xx but who's the lone
bella
come on show me the lone bellow okay
okay i see
it happened again i did it with meghan
trainor i introduced megan traynor to
millie vanilli
oh i know millie vanilli come on
um i love uh let's do
uh um i also love the xxx two sides
good right yeah is that corny am i no i
might be corny
um i feel like you might have heard this
it's like full
it's oh of course i have to listen to a
chase ad for this
i love this song um but uh
i like like folky gritty do you like
neil young
i don't know neil young okay so uh my
homework is to listen to the lone bella
bella bello i love his voice
beautiful it almost sounds bluegrass yes
and then this girl is this bitch
your computer screen is so filthy
it's disgusting
[Music]
i want to have my heart broken every
time i listen to a song
[Music]
so that's like beautiful that's amazing
thank you for that i love you
i don't want people to think i'm like
shading them by not knowing no
no we can cut it
but i do think it is really pretty yeah
i love like did you ever see a brother
martha
yes yeah like that soundtrack yeah just
like the bluegrass like heart-achingly
tragic bluegrass or do you know in the
cave yes yes
so like anything that just makes me feel
or i just want to be taken like to pop
land yes
on outer space spaceship where it rains
glitter and no one poops
yeah do you still want to act i do
actually want to act because i feel like
i have so much crazy people like love
you on jane the virgin
i was on it for like all of three
seconds i know but
it's like a thing no i actually been
thinking about it like
in like some sort of fucked up harmony
korean movie because you're so
shy that i'm surprised you have a
podcast i'm surprised you have
like you're not a very like i feel like
you get
forced to do things um
i have to like i get nervous to do
i think you say yes and then you're like
oh god i have to do it oh yeah yeah i
definitely do that with certain things
especially if it's someone i like really
respect like i'll get nervous like oh
driving here i was like
fuck i don't fuck up don't you suck but
that's why you're good
it's because i don't want to suck but
that's why you write amazing songs
you're like don't say
you know you have a high bar for your
yeah like if i write a mediocre song it
makes me look
i just like camp yeah that's why you're
you that's why you're wearing
teeth from scriptures on your body i
love them
um okay i know i have to let you go this
is my nightmare
um i'm gonna make you do this again
because i have so many more questions
um like
you're in the car what are you listening
to i'm in the car
driving here i was listening to your
podcast i'm serious that's
not even a lie i was and then before
that i
was i listening to like what oh i was
listening to um
wet ass pussy so it's like you
and what i suppose you're my most
recently
fair your algorithm knows you very well
um
are you going to live here forever uh on
this planet in los angeles
probably not are you i don't know are
you thinking about moving
as you redo your whole house me too
as i'm like hanging the art i'm like why
am i doing like looking at real i'm on
zillow looking where
where are you gonna go montana i don't
know i just want to see i was at first
in franklin for a second
franklin's beautiful i will say having
gone to school there
don't it was just very
the only time i got talked to is when i
straightened my hair and wore a capture
what do you think is the thing about you
that is the most
like misunderstood mine is i'll tell you
man yeah go
mine is people think i'm tough oh
people think i'm tough like i'll walk
down the street and people like hey cunt
and i'm like
oh my god yeah you just hurt my feelings
yeah yeah you know because you're a
comedian so you can't hurt your feelings
because you can make it funny
i've created the situation where i'm
like this super sensitive person
that everyone wants to joke with so now
i'm everyone's punching bag
and i'm like all the time yeah
and like i think i sense that because i
feel like i'm in our friendship it's
been very like
gentle yeah yeah what do you mean we've
very respectful which i think we both
need we both
know that we're like open wounds yeah
and like
what we do for a living is almost like
the art that comes from being sometimes
injured and sometimes just funny shit
happens and you write about it or
sometimes you just fall in love and you
write about or sometimes you
watch godzilla movie and you write about
it but like there's also
pain in art and sometimes the pain can
make the
art really fucking good and relatable
and i think so when i am around other
artists like
i'm really sensitive to the energy of
like there might be open wounds there
yeah because to make art i feel like you
feel
pain you have to be of some sort i mean
i don't know i think probably something
that's misunderstood about me i am
like the most because i because i
something this moment i i meant to bring
up earlier we were in the
car and we were talking about ghosts and
stuff
um and you were like i know like i have
sparkles on my face and you like you
you're so self-aware and i
it like just was so shocking to me
because you were like i know i have shit
on my face i have sparkles on my face
and shit so i sound like i'm crazy
like it was like it was like
mind-blowing because i want to look in
the mirror and feel like a decorated
christmas tree not
some like bare ass naked one like that's
how i feel about my face and body
like you're you live so hard i think i
love that about you
well fuck it you're the kid you know
what it is it's like
you're doing like it's never too late
to have the childhood you never had i
think the inner child is like something
that
she's like almost re-parent because i
went through all that like
shit in school where i'm like no i'm
gonna go back and like
embrace it in front of the entire world
for them to uncheck you're like that
didn't go well
i'm gonna regroup redo and do it on my
turn
yeah like yeah i'm going to wear a cape
i'm going to own it yeah you should see
my cape collection you would die
like i have multiple racks of capes
where my stylus is like
when do you wear a cape and i was like
me personally
or like the general public because me
personally i almost wore one today
like all the fucking time yeah like it's
like you were like uh that didn't
redo yeah you're like and i'm gonna be
proud of it and i'm gonna do in front of
people and i'm gonna be like
into it and i'm going to be like and
when you do i'm not going to go hide in
the bathroom and eat my lunch anymore
you do that it's like the
you give people permission to go yeah
i'm going to fucking
i'm going to do that too yeah like why
not
why not like me before you don't like me
anyway yeah you're committed to not
liking me
so i might as well do whatever so i
might as well just let it yeah
let now you're not gonna like me because
i'm having fun you didn't like me before
because i wanted your approval now you
don't like me because i'm having too
much i'm having way more fun than you
yeah so like
why am i even thinking about you who are
you we don't even know
well i know christie who just bitch from
middle school
[Music]
i love you we end these awkwardly and i
don't think there's any better way to
end that
than that until the round two cashed
around
oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]